liebe Freunde
hiermit eröffne ich die
europawahlversammlung an diesem Samstag
und stelle hiermit auch die
ordnungsgemäße Einberufung der Sitzung
fest und ich möchte auch anschließen
[Musik]
mit einem ganz großen dankeschön das
Dankeschön geht an sie alle ich weiß was
das bedeutet möglicherweise die
Sommerferien auch mit euren Familien zu
unterbrechen dementsprechend mein
herzliches Dankeschön für das
zahlreiche Erscheinen heute ja an dem
Wochenende
wir haben auch heute fast Halbzeit des
amtierenden Bundesvorstandes und da
möchte ich natürlich auch die
Möglichkeit ergreifen mich ganz herzlich
bei meinen lieben Kollegen des
Bundesvorstandes für die sehr gute
Zusammenarbeit zu bedanken und auch ein
herzliches Dankeschön an meinen lieben
co-sprecher Timo der auch der
co-sprecher im Fraktionsvorstand ist
vielen herzlichen Dank für die tolle
Zusammenarbeit es ist wirklich sehr
gedächtig und es macht uns beiden
unglaublich viel Spaß eine ganz große
Freude diese Partei in diesen Zeiten zu
führen vielen herzlichen Dank dafür
lieber Tino danke schön auch und das
möchte ich auch nicht missen an die
vielen da sehe ich sie mit den besten
an die vielen ehrenamtlichen Helfern wir
haben extrem viel vor der Brust dieses
und nächstes Wochenende vielen
herzlichen Dank an euch dass ihr euch
bereit erklärt habt hier mitzuhelfen
vielen herzlichen Dank an die
Mitarbeiter der Bundesgeschäftsstelle
das hier auf die Beine gestellt zu haben
schaut hier hin wie fleißig sie sind
gestern schon um 7 Uhr
angefangen bis spät in die Nacht merci
ist Dankeschön an euch
und
ich möchte gar nicht mich hier mit einer
langen Rede aufhalten weil wir extrem
viel zu tun haben aber vielleicht ein
paar Worte zu der Nervosität die so
greifbar ist also die Medien schlagen um
sich die anderen Parteien die
ampelregierung die CDU wir haben das
gesehen der März der verliert sich hier
in antidemokratischen Brandmauer
Debatten und Kontakt verboten ich kann
dazu einfach nur sagen
wir müssen nur eine Brandmauer
niederreißen und das ist die Brandmauer
der CDU im Osten wo wir als AFD bereits
jetzt stärkste Kraft sind ich kann
einfach nur sagen
heute sehen in Ostdeutschland ist erst
der Anfang wir sind führend in den
Umfragen und wir werden die Umfragen
unsere Ergebnisse bis zu den
Landtagswahlen noch ausbauern ausbauen
und dann kommt niemand mehr an uns ans
stärkster Kraft vorbei reißt die
Brandmauer nieder sie sind
antidemokratisch
und auch noch mal ein paar Worte an die
Altparteien
wie anti-demokratisch ist das Millionen
von Wählern die wirbinden einfach
auszuschließen würde uns einfallen in
jemanden auszuschließen wir reden mit
jedem wir müssen auch mit jedem reden
das ist unsere Pflicht gegenüber den
Wählern und vor allen Dingen auch
gesellschaftspolitische Debatten
anzustoßen weil ansonsten ist die
Polarisierung viel zu groß und wir
erreichen überhaupt gar kein
gesellschaftspolitischen Konsens das ist
unsere Aufgabe als Partei und das
einzige was wir brauchen
ist ein Bollwerk gegen das grüne
Narrenschiff was dieses Land in Grund
und Boden regiert
die Grünen sind nichts anderes als die
neue verboten
und die AFD ist die einzige Partei die
konservative Partei der Freiheit und des
Unternehmertums und der Arbeitnehmer wir
sind die Partei der Steuerzahler in
diesem Land
noch ein paar Worte zur EU die EU ist so
tiefst und demokratisch und übergriffig
sie greift in unsere privaten Planung
ein in unsere Lebensgestaltung in die
Unternehmensgestaltung in die
Unternehmensbesteuerung und dort wo sie
eigentlich Sinn machen würde versagt sie
komplett und zwar das Versagen in der
Migrationspolitik wir müssen die
überbordene Migration stoppen liebe
Freunde
was wir brauchen ist ein Europa der
Vaterländer
ein Konstrukt einer Europa der
Vaterländer ein kompetenzrückbau und die
Kompetenzen dahin zu verlagern wo die
gewählten Volksvertreter in den
Parlamenten sitzen ja und das sind die
Nationalstaaten wir treten ein für die
Stärkung der Nationalstaaten innerhalb
der EU das ist unser Ziel und wir treten
auch dafür ein dass wir als Deutsche
über elementare europäische Fragen die
unsere Souveränität betreffen natürlich
selbst abstimmen dürfen in
Volksabstimmung das ist unser Ziel
warum wir noch eine starke Delegation im
Europäischen Parlament brauchen ist wir
müssen eine Festung Europa bauen wir
brauchen die Festung Europa zum Schutz
unserer Heimat und das machen wir
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
Partnern liebe Freunde
die AFD und unsere Partner wir sind doch
die einzige Kraft gegen die überbordene
Korruption innerhalb der EU ein paar
Worte zur Ursula von der Leyen was fällt
eigentlich einer
kommissionspräsidentin CDU gestellte im
Übrigen ein
Geheimverträge mit Pfizer über
Impfstoffe zu schließen wo im Nachgang
E-Mails und Chats gelöscht werden wo
nichts mehr auffindbar ist unsere
Aufgabe ist diesen Korruption Sumpf
trockenzulegen und diese Leute zur
Rechenschaft zu ziehen
und aus diesem Grund wünsche ich uns
allen eine gedeihliche eine konstruktive
Aufstellungsversammlung lasst uns eine
starke Truppe eine sehr starke Gruppe
ins Europäische Parlament schicken und
ich wünsche uns allen viel Freude und
viel Spaß ich bedanke mich herzlich für
die Aufmerksamkeit danke
ich leite damit nahtlos über zum Top 2
und schlage im Namen des
Bundesvorstandes den Versammlungsleiter
Christoph Basedow vor ich würde gerne
die Wahl offen durchführen regt sich
hier Widerspruch
das kann ich nicht erkennen gibt es
Gegenstimmen zur Wahl von Christoph
Basedow
gibt es Enthaltung damit ist die Wahl
von Christoph Basedow
einstimmig angenommen ich bedanke mich
herzlich Christoph stehst du zur
Verfügung
ja also ich bitte Herrn Basel du auf die
Bühne beziehungsweise an das
versammlungs
bitte übernehmen